this year's winner in the operator
category receives the ftth award in
recognition for rolling out advanced
fiber networks in rural areas located in
the north and south and port of Portugal
with an investment of 19 million euros
this operator installed more than 9,000
kilometers of optical fiber cable to
cover more than fifty percent of the
households in these regions ladies and
gentlemen the ftth council europe
operator award is given to portuguese
operator des telecom
and to receive this award let me welcome
onto the stage mr. Xavier order against
Martine member of the board and call my
president Karen owl to present the
trophy
members of the Polish government
regulator chairman of greg the a fatty
ma you authorities president of the ftth
Europe Council ladies and gentlemen dear
friends good morning everybody it's an
unexpected pleasure to be here with you
today is such a beautiful venue was such
a beautiful city I just wanted to say
three words the first one is a big thank
you first of all to the ftth zero
council was such as so much appreciated
recognition secondly to our shareholder
the DST group for the Restless soup or
in creating a new narrative for rural
broadband then to the pole to the
authorities to create an environment
where companies like dias telecom can
offer broadband rural broadband services
at the same price on quality that the
equivalent human services there is more
than elephants in the jungle in this
telecom jungle thank you to our clients
for the business the retail operators
they use our wholesale services and
finally a big thank you to our fabulous
team for their creativity and their
enthusiasm to innovate every day and to
overcome the challenges that we have to
implement such a big project my second
word is a call to action to the european
authorities to double the effort to
create the conditions institutional
conditions in financial conditions to
accelerate the deployment of the network
and the acceptance and the and the
penetration of the services and my final
word is a word of encouragement an
encouragement to you all to us all the
ftth family to continue fighting to
reinvent our business every day to find
inspiration in small companies like des
telecom and unlikely countries like
Portugal to really reinvent and find new
paths for the industry every day and to
encourage all of us to continue fighting
to make out of optical fiber such a
beautiful symbol
of a richer and a bridal Europe thank
you very much